hey youtubers up next adam savage
talks about building stuff
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrass tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and we're coming to you from my office
at the hayden planetarium of the
american museum of natural history
right here in new york city co-host
today chuck nice job hey neil
always good to be here at the cosmic
crib and who are we making a sandwich
with here
we've seen him before yes we have we did
the one the only
the inimitable adam savage yeah
welcome back thank you very much like
your third time on star talk it's been
too long since i've been in this office
and it's been too long we enjoyed your
last visit
and i feel like we're lifelong friends
even though we've only had a few times
together
it feels like culturally where we're
culturally yeah we like
bouncing the cultural venn diagram has
quite the area where you two overlap and
that creates the friendship even without
does individual time together i see what
you're doing and i think oh that's
awesome
that's great cool man so we've got you
on you actually have a new book
i do holy cow i'll talk about your book
i'll do the talking about you
okay all right okay okay that looks
better doesn't it that is that's called
public relations when he talks about his
book it's bragging
it's black when you talk about it it's
public relations there you go but enough
about me what did you think of my book
so every tool is a hammer great title
and this you know my my favorite picture
in here is
there's a lot of interesting pictures
like you and your workshop and your my
favorite is
the stuff that you dumped out of your
backpack oh but then neatly organized
that which is cool i like seeing what's
it and i like um
john hodgman's comment he said this this
is a map
of his brain nice that's i thought that
was a very good comment
i feel like venturing into that unknown
territory yeah yeah for some people you
don't want to go there
right but for adam savage yeah you want
to see what's what have what what drop
what's been driving him his whole life
that is so funny some people you don't
want to go there just my wife left her
she journals and it was out of journals
she journals and so
the journal was on the bed no you did
not no i'm laying on the bed
and watching tv the journal is sitting
right there she comes in the room she
goes
oh my god i left my journal up and she
goes you didn't read it did you when i
went
i don't want to know what's going on
i don't want any parts of what is
happening in europe if your wife said
i hope you didn't read my journal that
does not bode well yeah i know what
movie
exists in which someone read someone
else's journal and it all turned out
great
my good point yeah that's so funny there
ain't no movie about that right
now i used to my twin boys used to like
sit in their bunk beds and talk every
night and
my mom was like what are they talking
about i'm like i don't know that's their
private moment i'm not going to listen
i don't want to know let them have their
moments i want to know what's on
in his head and so does our fan base now
that is so true because i have their
questions
because this is a cosmic queries edition
of
star talk and we just solicited our fan
base
questioned knowing they'd land in the
lap of adam sam savage
about just making stuff yeah and so so
chuck i haven't seen them you
you chuck reviewed them just this
morning reviewing them and okay and adam
hasn't seen him so let's see what you
got
yeah and these are cool and as usual we
always start with a patreon patron
because
they support us because we're that low
we well no we're that high we're that
high
okay and we have supporters i want to be
a member of patreon so that i could get
my questions answered but
you can you can actually donate to
patreon and then ask yourself a question
that's how i get on that list
that's what i will do i will ask myself
that would be funny all right i'll do
that all right here we go this is a bike
and bird says
um hey adam we've all heard of examples
of
items or procedures getting discovered
by accident
microwaves penicillin even chocolate
chip cookies
through all of your different
experiments was there an
outcome or product that was produced
that was
applied to another test
or maybe even applications outside of
the show
um and this is that kind of like in
texas did he invent anything
by accident it was a long way it was a
long walk around the block that was a
whole
that was off the off ramp exactly the
clover leaf
exactly to get back on i have a comment
and a question but an autograph
biographical story first
um actually there's a word for that in
science is serendipity
okay yes a great word uh there was a
moment
i can't think of anything we invented by
accident but i do remember we were on
discovery
we were on hawaii doing on mythbusters
shooting duct tape island
and this was the conceit jamie and i get
stranded on it jimmy your co-host from
from mythbusters so jamie heinemann and
i get stranded on a deserted island and
all we have is a pallet
of several hundred rolls of duct tape
what do we do
that's so we wait wait so
so is macgyver tuning into this episode
right right
more things to do with duct tape exactly
okay so we made shelter we've
we actually made traps and caught
chickens we ended up making a 21 foot
long
outrigger canoe at with which we were
able to get past the breakwater of the
north shore of oahu
uh but there was a moment when jamie was
asked to make a a
a still for uh distilling um uh clean
water sorry fresh water
from the salt water okay and so he was
digging into the beach to make a hole
and the procedure is you dig into the
beach you make a hole it's going to be a
kind of a damp hole because it's on the
beach
and you let sit in some plastic with a
rock in the middle
and as water condenses from the salt
water collects on the inside of the
membrane you've put
you can catch it in a cup and drink
fresh water
however jamie noticed that when he dug
in and tasted just the water that was
being filtered through the sand that it
was much less brackish and salty and so
he got really excited about the idea
that the sand of the beach itself was
filtering the water interesting and
we explained that this was a whole
episode about duct tape and while this
was really interesting
it really didn't fit within our
narrative right but he kept insisting
and so we ended up shooting this whole
sequence with jamie which i think we put
on the web
because that was the most interesting
part of that day for him was the idea
that the sand filtered the salt out
but this was a classic thing of jamie
going uh this is the thing i'm
interested in and we're saying no that's
not what the episode's about
he's like i don't care what you're
saying make a new episode to talk about
this thing
and now i love all my water gritty yeah
just a little bit
i need just a little bit grit in all of
my water drink it out of my boot thank
you
cool all right cool next great story
great story great story uh this is john
cole from facebook who says between star
talk
and the tested youtube channel i am
in heaven hello adam how do you
get over the maker's equivalent
of writer's block wow this is a great
question
john cole you are thinking my friend so
so do you ever just walk into your
garage and say i don't know what i'm
going to put together today totally
but more than that i also hit moments
where i spent a whole day assembling
something and realized that i've ascend
assembled it chirally backwards and that
it's the mirror image without the mirror
nice oh
that was much more concise that was way
better than where you were going yeah it
was i was
being way too wordy because you can make
something that is the mirror image of
itself
right and then you hold them together in
their mirror images exactly and our
amino acids
are have one chirality and they all have
the same chirality for
all life on earth and when we found
amino acids in
asteroids we found that they were 50 50
oh of both chiralities so we knew that
it didn't care
and there wasn't one life form because
amino acids aren't alive yet
that overran the other so our chirality
is the one chirality in the whole world
and there's suspicions that if there's
another life form with the other
chirality
of our molecules that you wouldn't be
able to metabolize them if you oh
wow because the the molecules wouldn't
fit together together so they might not
even be able to taste it
right oh that's cool and they would
probably be
like a guy one half of his face would be
black
and the other half of his face would be
white and it's really angry and sweet
and he's right
exactly wow but act so from a standpoint
of making whenever you have two parts
that are chiral
it can be a devilishly difficult
assembly problem because
everything looks very similar but the
order of operations is very precise
tetris is kind of like that too two of
the pieces are mirror opposite each
other right yeah so regularly in making
you hit a spot where you
sorry 3d tetris i was thinking sorry so
you hit a spot where you've screwed
something up and you feel i feel really
dejected about it and i don't feel like
moving forward
or i don't feel like undoing the five
hours of work i've just done
wow and i'm ex i'm angry i'm i'm pissed
off i feel sad about it
um that's funny because i feel the same
way whenever i put anything together
from ikea
[Laughter]
it's chuck the table is upside down
really yes
totally like he is absolutely ripe for
that kind of
screwing up but go ahead well so and how
does everything fit in a flat box anyway
is this something that should not be
able to fit in a flat box
the ikea card okay all right sorry i'll
go ahead
there's a there's a line from uh uh uh
mary carr who wrote liars club wrote
about
uh about what she does with writer's
block and she says if i can't think
about what to write
i sit at my desk and i copy writers i
love in longhand because my fidelity
at the desk is to be writing whether
it's my own writing or not
wow what an exercise it's a beautiful
exercise and i take that to heart in the
shop if i can't think of what to make i
organize something in my shop a drawer a
shelf
a bin i take something and i adjust it
because
so you do shop time i do shop time and i
do so much more shop time than i ever
did before because i realized it's a
deep part of that whole process of
prepping the shop and prepping myself
for the work
i do a little bit something like that i
have a book called um
the greatest wits of all time and
they're phrases out of letters and
correspondence
from people that have extraordinary wit
and i just read it wow that was an
awesome
juxtaposition of words or phrases or
rhythm and that just sort of
re-baptizes me into a mood right that i
then say okay i'm ready
it feels fertile there you go yeah so do
you ever
suffer writer's block block me no i go
through this exercise i have a lot of
books written by writers who like
writing about writing
also about whatever else they wrote
about right did that sentence
it's a lot of deception i would never
want to write that sentence that's only
a speakable sentence
and so and there's one sentence that i i
think i uttered this in our last
recording
a sentence from the great gatsby this is
this is a sentence where i knew
i still have not become a great writer
and maybe never will
oh wow okay i i have to hear this now
in his blue gardens
men and girls came and went
like moths amid
the whispers the champagne and the stars
that's a great i i can't i read that and
say that's why
i am not a novelist yes and he is
one of my favorite pastors obviously
this is uh from the great gatsby
that's his party yeah yeah you're
reminding me of a line from chandler
that that's that's
that's like a perfect simile plus you
mentioned and went ahead as mobs
yes as monsters very elegant the
whispers
of the champagne and the stars
incredible
you know i didn't come here to feel
inadequate
and yeah and yeah and yet here we are
so what were we saying adam i'm saying
it reminds me of this line from chandler
where his hero marlo is sitting in a
waiting room for too long and he
describes the time passing us
the minutes tiptoed by their fingers to
their lips
lovely okay okay so uh i
have one it's a quote from my father uh
seriously what the hell are you still
doing here
you haven't moved out of the basement
yet that's a talk every father has all
right uh
it might be we got we got adam here
because he's got a new book yes we would
have him anyway even without the book
let me just make that clear absolutely i
appreciate it okay but he was made
available to us by simon schuster
okay um for free right he was like in
new york
doing media and i guess we count as
media you do we do yeah
nice i can handle that uh every tool is
a hammer life
is what you make it i see what he did
there yeah that's very cool that's right
right so adam
every tool is a hammer actually does
sound like something donald trump would
say though i'm just saying
you know the phrase of mine he's grabbed
is i reject your reality and substitute
my own
very that's is that a nice
from you that is yeah and he actually
quoted that no he hasn't quote
but he's just living in the entire life
he's just living in it
okay i love it all right let us
let's take mitch morris who comes
together well with the words
with their names today that's because
they're regular names regular yeah
regular narrative
how racist can you get i i can get a lot
more
i'm just letting you know since we're
asking
all right but you are right
that is uh it's extremely um what do you
call it um
presumptive of me all right here we go
mitch morris from instagram
um uh miss mars from instagram wants to
know this
what is the most important tool ever
invented that's for the both of you
what an interesting little question very
simple little question but very
interesting
i'll answer first because i want him to
bring closure to that question
yeah so so when i was younger i said wow
this crescent wrench is really
useful right because you can adjust it
and then
i discovered the miter saw no no
no no the the vice grip the vice grip oh
and i saw i've died and gone to heaven
yeah vice grip
and then and then you got better than
vice grip yes
okay the most important tool is money to
pay somebody
you may have just answered the question
okay
i have to say in the circles i travel in
a crescent wrench is known as a nut
corner rounder
and the vice grips are known as the
professional nut corner rounder okay
they they can mess up don't get me wrong
i love both
means taking your hex and removing the
edges too yeah until it can no longer be
not corner rounded i uh i have to go
to the simplest i mean one of the six
simple machines the lever i feel like
the ability to move heavy objects
with with the mechanical advantage and
the lever
the lever com the lever exists before
the wheel or any rollers to me
his modeling archimedes who said give me
a lever and a place to stand and i can
move the world i don't think he said
lever he just
give me a place to stand give me a place
i think he was describing the other yes
of course
but i'm saying he that was implicit
he doesn't give me a lever and a place
just give me a place to stand
and i can move the world beautiful there
you go
yeah yeah next question all right good
stuff okay leave her i'll give you a
little lever lever next question here's
the next question
from woman shop
[Laughter]
neil and adam you guys are both my
heroes which would you
say will be the more important for the
future of invention
good old-fashioned mechanical know-how
or advances
in material science i.e inventing a new
type of suspension bridge
that is stronger and lighter versus
discovering a stronger and lighter
titanium alloy okay we don't have time
to answer that oh
there you go more when we come back of
the maker's edition of cosmic queries
this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service made for viewers with
inquiring minds
including star talk fans just like you
get access starting at 299 a month let
me tell you about
curiosity streams how to build series
if you're a person that's a maker and
you want to step up your garage
game well this is the show for you it
gives you
unprecedented access to some of the
world's most advanced engineers who are
responsible for satellites
supercars and the wings of jumbo jets
their satellites episode is really cool
they talk about how to build a machine
that will live
for over a decade in space
and of course how it will deal with the
harshness of the environment of space
and the suspense about getting it into
orbit go to curiositystream.com
star talk for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series
and for our listeners enter the promo
code star talk when you're prompted
during the sign up process
and your membership is completely free
for the first 31 days
and now back to adam savage on star talk
we're back star talk adam savage the one
and only
of mythbusters fame and he's
he's running on his own making stuff
he's got a new book out called every
tool's a hammer
life is what you make it you see what he
did there chuck that never knows
he he did that i got chuck nice with me
yes and we're doing cosmic queries yes
we are before we went to break we had a
question from woo moo shop who says
hi neil and adam you guys are both my
heroes which would you say will be the
more important for the future of
invention good old-fashioned mechanical
know-how or advancements in material
science
uh good old-fashioned mechanical
know-how we are always going to be
advancing in materials science and there
will sometimes be things that we cannot
replicate because we lose a technology
or we forget
a process but as long as we have a deep
foundation in
mechanical knowledge in making things
and the roots of the physics of putting
stuff together
we can utilize those advances and we can
adjust to the changes in
the available materials as they come
wow great i only kind of agree with that
oh
i'm agreeing 50 oh okay
i i'm i'm into material science it is
one of the most
under appreciated unheralded branches of
science
in this world okay all right if you go
back
50 years hardly any
no i'm not i'm not bragging about this
advance i'm just citing it as a
difference in our lives you go back 50
years
hardly anything was made of plastic
correct
and almost everything is made of plastic
today
and it's working out great for many
things as long as as long as you don't
have to throw it away
okay it's working great the plastic is
stronger it's more reliable
than other materials and you can mold it
and just
think of the things that having simple
quote um standard mechanical knowledge
would is so what that look what this
material can do
with their their materials now that have
memory of a shape they once had
okay so you can deform and sleep on it
then you'd like wet it and then it goes
back to the previous shape
i got nothing to do nothing in your lab
nothing in your garage
is ready for that but but within the one
is better than the other
mechanical knowledge can push humanity
forward
on its own whereas material science
can't necessarily with the good
materials you don't need the mechanical
knowledge
built into the material itself oh
smackdown meet me in the octagon
yes we actually so uh
as an aside we just i just finished a
new show for the science channel called
savage builds in which i build absurd
things every week
in the first episode we made a suit of
iron man armor in 3d printed titanium
speaking of material science i
discovered that when you 3d print
titanium
you can attenuate its grain structure so
that it is
far stronger than normal titanium mm-hmm
because we can give it these super tight
little crystalline grains and get closer
right yeah
wow wait except that makes it denser
it seems to be in this case no it's
still 45
the weight of steel interesting okay
okay that's stronger stronger if you
made it denser you would lose some of
the value of it being light yeah no this
stuff was amazing we had potato chip
thin
pieces uh they were bulletproof bullets
slid right off of this oh wait a minute
is this something that was
already discovered oh yeah is it just no
he is using 3d printed titanium in their
jet engines
right now okay absolutely property that
you discovered no no
no
there's an amazing engineering school
called the colorado school of minds
yes everyone knows that those guys are
incredible and i worked directly with
them in their additive manufacturing
department
okay so he just figured out a brilliant
new material to make armor for nights
[Laughter]
600 years late
[Laughter]
that's great yeah but i i i can't wait
to see what new material
is coming down the pipe and what how
that might transform how we live
i think about that all the time okay
yeah all right all right excellent
question once again from our listening
audience and just
just for the point of interest we trans
we transition from
ooh that's cheap it's made of plastic to
oh that's made of plastic fine
i don't have any problems it'll it'll
last forever right that was that
that happened in we're about the same
age that happened in our lifetime it did
yes it did okay just i
totally agree just i just want i don't
want to smack you down too hard
just just the octagon will decide this
okay does anyone know the octagon i'm
sure they do and there's a lot of ufc
fans
i don't know what the venn diagram is
yeah
right now there's a guy uh calculating
an equation of kick ass
all right now this is mike uh pumacking
per pump making pump making i don't know
okay uh mike said these people i think
they're just screwing with me you think
so
i really do they're like is it chalk
we're gonna just make up names
all right here we go mr savage what is
something
that you would think will be possible to
build in the future
that is now considered science fiction
very good that's a great question room
temperature super conduction
wow wow you went for a big one i did
no i'm really excited about speaking of
material science i'm really excited
about this raffine and came back
came back to me that's true material
science
all right so is that your that's your
answer that's my answer room temperature
superconduction is going to be a
i believe it will happen in our
lifetimes i think that
uh and once that happens will we
actually be able to have
you know spaceships that stop and hover
and i don't know well
at least we'll be actually we'll
probably one of the things we'll learn a
significant amount about is the
is our brains is whether it's the
processing power of our brains there's a
i feel like as computers become more
powerful they're going to become a real
interesting window
into consciousness and sentience and
what it is to
think about the thinker nice you know i
hadn't quite put
her to put that way but now that i have
i agree 100
because it's hard for the brain to study
itself
but if we make computers that are
becoming better better
approximations of our brain now we have
something we can study
and so we would asymptotically come to
an understanding of our brain
simply by making our computers that much
more complex
possibly one day achieving consciousness
themselves and becoming our overlords
there you go that's how the story is i
think if we ever made a machine
conscious the first thing it's going to
say to us is
what the [ __ ] did you do that's so true
all right next question all right cool
good good good question cosmic query's
version
uh start talk i let's see now here's
somebody
uh he calls himself or herself
the dragon horde of dice dragon horde
there you go that person mama probably
did not give that person that name
no but uh i think it's i think her name
is kate because it says
uh at katenator okay so there you go
hey for adam since i know you do
cosplay what is the most complex
mechanical prop
costume you've ever tried to build like
a prop or costume that had no moving
parts or could collapse expand
uh or something that you may have tried
to just recreate did you make
transformers proud ever
oh gosh no i have not done a
transformers costume
um a few years ago i've i've been
obsessed with armor
uh since 1981 when i went and saw
excalibur with my dad i love excalibur
john borman's my top
five favorite films amazing and then i
learned disturbingly
yeah yeah the fact you're about to tell
me go ahead oh
really no no no maybe not i don't know
the fact please i'm excuse my having a
private conversation with my man here
okay so excalibur in the early 1980s
john borman an early film that had uh
patrick stewart in it patrick stewart
liam neeson liam neeson's in it and
gabriel burns and so
is um helen mirren helen they're all in
this movie
okay it's the king arthur's story so
thank you
much later i realized
i think half the reason why i like the
movie was because of the soundtrack
oh it is very powerful wagnerian
um and that which is not wagnerian comes
from
carmina burana very emotional energetic
music that you're just feeling every
scene and i thought to myself
maybe the movie's not so good but the
music was amazing and that completely
compensated for it i watched it recently
it's still
super campy and still really
impressively great but did you watch it
on mute
no with subtitles and mute
try that next i did not apply a control
chakra okay
okay so what's so your answer uh so i've
been obsessed with armor since then
and i actually when i was a junior in
high school in 1984 i
went to i built a suit of armor out of
roofing aluminum with my dad
and wore it to school on halloween and
passed out of heat exhaustion in third
period
this is all up just up north at sleepy
hollow high school
uh hence your twitter handle don't try
this exactly
uh and at home a few years ago i called
up terry english who's the master
armorer that built all the armor for
excalibur he lives in the southern tip
of england in cornwall
and i went to his studio a couple
summers ago and spent
10 days embedded with him as his
assistant while he and i
manufactured me a suit of king arthur's
armor from excalibur you were an
apprentice
i was an apprentice and we made me my
lifetime goal suit of armor of arthur's
armor from excalibur
wow that's pretty intense it was so
intense it was amazing he lives in this
incredible sort of overgrown
shop in cornwall um he's so he is you
in england yeah
there's only room for one per continent
i think i don't know
[Laughter]
that was by far my favorite mechanical
prop construction oh wow
but it was not it was not electronic or
anything no mechanical hammering
aluminum all day
chain mail and everything yeah there's
yup absolutely man wow that's pretty
wild man that hey congratulations on
that
and you still have it oh yeah yeah i
wear it every chance i get how do you
get through
tsa um i actually i when i
whatever they were known back then no i
made i actually uh took it to new
zealand last year to make a little film
with peter jackson about it where a
demon tears my arm off we called it a
farewell to arms
okay things are getting weird real
quickly here when i carried the armor
with me i was thinking
this is this is priceless to me i can't
really ensure this
so i i checked it as luggage with a gps
transceiver in my luggage so i could
monitor it being loaded onto my
plane that's pretty wild i felt if the
airline was going to tell me they
couldn't find it i wanted to know that i
could find it i got to tell you
something
plane goes down they can't find the
black box
yeah we have no idea why
all these people are dead but we do have
an
awesome suit of armor right now
oh my god wow man that's crazy that's
pretty wild
you're far weirder than i ever but wait
a minute
compliment yes wait you i know your
jackson are making home movies
occasionally what's going on and for
those who didn't know
the um the lord of the rings series was
mostly filmed in new zealand by peter
jackson and peter jackson was inspired
to
one of the key inspirations for him in
making lord of the rings was excalibur
so i'm not the only one who likes next
count no it's my top five most important
film
but other four are really weird not that
but that's in there
that's sweet okay i i can't say it's one
of my favorite
yeah okay yeah i'm i'm not cool enough
all right i need help
here we go uh this one other thing let's
go ahead
these five movies are like the only five
movies i've ever
not only seen a zillion times but sat
through the director's
um narration right yeah director's
commentary
the director's commentary because you
have to like the movie so much that
you'll see you don't
and here's somebody just talk through it
yep nice that was well you've also seen
it that many times well that's part
that's that's how you earn the
director's cut at that point exactly
yeah
yeah right all right now i got to know
what are the other forms yeah no i do
too really yeah
because if that's if that's part of the
top five yes and that means there's four
other movies that you need
to director's cut number one the matrix
okay that's good
i'll give you that number two all that
jazz
with bob foster okay this
okay three the conversation
ah such a good movie oh man man now
coupler oh hopefully it's a conversation
conversation
conversation uh and then that there's
probably a
toss up here but the
[Music]
um uh west side story amazing
that's great and uh and then
excalibur i think it's fifth out of
those five i look i say there's at least
nine films in my top five wow
top five that's good the top five lists
actually can go quantum and we can
fit lots and lots of dimension on this
exactly you've got timelines on your
on your so so those five are so unlike
each other and there's what an eclectic
mix it's really weird but i've totally
so i used to dance okay so hence the bob
fosse
have you done dancing with the stars no
that's that's that's so
i don't know i know it is but okay i
suddenly
want to see you on my show when i was
dancing no one was publishing my books
i don't need to dance anymore okay so so
what chuck do you love scripture serious
do you love strictly
dancing for nobody okay
[Applause]
my people have come a long way
okay okay all right so so
there's that and i i wrote a a column
for a magazine
under the pen name of merlin so i have
extra
interest in the merlin arthurian legends
and i have the mallory book in
vellum you know so there's that matrix
of course is the main matrix one of
course it's just
absolutely perfect has to be there there
are two other movies and the
conversation was just
so so well done
amazing and and no explosions there's no
chase scenes
okay it was a story well done
and so so there i am nice those are my
five now
but listen so l there you go people now
you know what you're doing uh
netflix and chill with neil's list
that's a weird list what a weird list of
netflix netflix
story is new york it's it's the city
it's i'm half puerto rican uh my
mother's name is francita malia
fediciano
tyson okay that's her name west side
story is such a masterpiece
and is it masterpiece masterpiece
masterpiece
and while i don't know how to compose
music
if i ever could i'm imagining that i
could compose the music
story wow that's where i'm thinking
that's what i would reach for and
that would be your north star that was
my that'd be my north star i like
beautiful he's beautiful
i love adam this episode is brought to
you by curiosity stream
a subscription streaming service made
for viewers with inquiring minds
including star talk fans just like you
get access starting at 299 a month
join curiosity stream to hold you over
between new episodes of star talk radio
come on we only put out an hour of star
talk on youtube
every week so you've got some time to
kill they've got some other cool shows
on topics like science history
nature and society lots of cool people
involved in these shows as well
sigourney weaver jane goodall sylvia
earle
and so many more go to
curiositystream.comstarttalk for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series
and for our listeners enter the promo
code star talk when you're prompted
during the sign up process
and your membership is completely free
for the first 31 days
and now back to adam savage on
star talk
back for our third and final segment and
i don't want this this
show to end yeah this is a good show
maker
cosmic queries edition uh with adam
savage who makes stuff
every tool is a hammer life is what you
make it
and this is you know it's a it's a it's
a window into your brain
oh yeah there's some organized shelves i
like the fact that you have photos in it
thanks
oh yeah uh to thank your publisher for
agreeing to they don't always agree to
put pictures in their books no they did
i threw tons into the manuscript and
after we were after we had the
manuscript approved they said okay so
you're responsible for all the
permissions
publishers such wimps when it comes to
that oh man don't get me started
yeah so so definitely so next question
what was that all right so
this was uh elaine from minnesota who
said
as a builder i remember failed projects
more than the successes
true so tell me about failures relative
to success
well and we talk about this a lot these
days failure is a really popular word
and silicon valley says
you know build fast and break things we
talk about educating kids we talk about
teaching them how to fail
and i have a particular take on this
because i think failure is a fine word
but there's a version of that from the
90s or 80s which
which was shocking when we first heard
it was
if it ain't broke break it break it yes
so that way you might invent something
better than the thing you had before
and just because it worked doesn't mean
that's the best version of what it could
be indeed or you just end up with a lot
of broken [ __ ]
that's if you're not creative there's
always broken [ __ ]
don't heed that advice all right so go
ahead but we don't really mean
failure um wrong turns on the path to
get to a success
are not failures they're simply
iterations
and i i i'm here and that's not a
euphemism or anything no
my my smells like one what i want to
preach is that both science and art are
iterative processes that include
tons of wrong turns and the wrong turns
aren't outliers they're part of that
process
and we go up the path and we're like
okay this isn't the path so let's go
back to the fork and
continue down another path and see if
that's the path and so yes i also
remember my failures more than my
successes because that's where i learned
the failures or the the failures the
wrong turns i took
to get to the right turns are the are
the places that i learned the most about
myself and about how to build things and
about how to recover
from those moments you know what they
say about rocket launch failures
that they're not failures they're just
experiments rich in data
but this is exactly right there's always
the guy who says my experiment was a
failure
no scientist says no no no no no we
don't we don't actually it's
well designed a negative result is
actually useful information
indeed publishable information we don't
have you have to say that when somebody
else is paying for what you do
yeah but but all of our this i was just
reading an article the other day about
how science how journals publishing
journals
don't highlight no results they don't
value it in the people
don't value it yeah and we should and we
should it's a problem
that's true i've never thought of that
but yeah there
is a great deal of the value it tells
you what not to do
exactly it tells the next person look
this is what i did
it didn't work out and now i don't have
to waste time
going down that because scientific
inquiry that is equally as important as
some brand new facts oh no that makes
a lot of sense you know chuck has has a
new hero of the recent months
who may have been responsible for
sending us down the wrong people
because his his his mantra was failure
is not an option
this was from apollo 13. and this is uh
gene krantz so it's failure is not an
option and then that became america
we're not going to fail and then we lost
track of the value of failure
we lost the most surprising thing i
learned from doing mythbusters for 13
years
was what how surprisingly creative the
scientific discipline is
and how it mirrors the creative
discipline to me
conducting experiments conducting and
building experimental methodologies is
every bit as creatively satisfying as
making a sculpture painting a painting
or writing a book i agree 100
but i think it's better when you call it
a wrong turn the way you put it that way
because if you think about it just from
the from
a standpoint everybody can uh identify
drivers
driver's standpoint when you make a
wrong term how many times have you done
that and discovered
something that you really like oh
there's a botanical gardens over here oh
there's
oh my god that process is the soul of
stand-up comedy oh absolutely
right iterate always every joke every
joke
even listen it's the same process even
when the joke works yes
you go back and you try to crack it open
and see
how can i make this even better indeed
if it works no absolutely yeah all right
super cool
wow lane what a great question you're a
hero lane that's what you are
you are all right this is chris goes to
the park thank you chris
[Music]
all right thanks chris uh he says hey
adam are there any inventions your team
created
on mythbusters that you have kept
or that you might still use today
p.s loved your show growing up it
inspired me to study engineering now i'm
an engineer
oh always amazing to hear
um there's nothing that we kept from the
public on mythbusters
except for one thing ooh carrie gretna
torrey
i didn't understand the question do you
mean is there something you made on miss
buster's that the public never saw
or no is there something that you can do
with here something we came up with or
that we discovered on mythbusters that
we have somehow kept from the public
that's not how i read the world well no
he meant i but i like that but
is there anything that you invented or
came up that you were like wow this is
so good i'm actually going to put it to
use in my life right that's how i
read it yeah wow yes
i mean like really it was the more the
process of telling the stories on
mythbusters
i mean but wait that's not as
interesting a question as the one you
thought about
all right let's assume there's a
question you thought exactly which is
carrick and tory were testing the
explosive carry
sorry my co-hosts on mythbusters carrie
byron tori belachie and grant imahara
uh they were testing a story uh that
involved a commonly available
commonly available material that is as
close to
a description as i'm going to get and
its explosive properties and what they
determined with this use case scenario
was so spectacularly terrifyingly
explosive
that we agreed to destroy the footage of
the explanation and never
tell how we got to that and i thank you
for that oh yeah no
yeah bomb squads the world over know
what we
figured out on on our own right uh and
are thankful that we've decided not to
put that in the episode
so yeah it's like yeah but our engineer
ben just found it on youtube
did you know if you took cotton balls
and chewing gum you could actually bring
down the world trade
center like what like yeah no that's
crazy yeah so all right
so the answer is yes you did yes yes yes
so you you quarantined that information
you did
and just sit to hell with it the world
doesn't need it it will not be better
for the
this bit of knowledge okay now just
between us what was the
what was the what were the materials
[Laughter]
all right this is ringa millie
who says how do you create new things
that
haven't before been thought of in other
words what is your
process for uh creative discovery
right you know is there any process that
says well you know what
boom well i don't know if there's i
don't know if it's reasonable to think
about something as
i want to make something that's never
been thought of i don't think we have
that
the choice to to sequester an
invention or a build or something
creative into a category before it's
been made
and everything we made is based on
everything that we've seen
so just as uh is it newton that said we
stand on the shoulders of giants yes
justice newton says that we we all do
it's called if i see farther than others
it is because i stood on the shoulders
of giants who have come before me and
that is one of the greatest descriptions
of culture
that anyone's ever penned uh that that's
exactly what's happening uh
when i was you know especially now when
i was 17 i saw alien
it took me five years to get the
aesthetic of h.r giger out of my system
i had to
recapitulate the aesthetics that he was
doing because i found it so powerful
until i kind of understood it
that recapitulates so that person is the
what to the movie
yeah he h.r gigger designed the aliens
you said that like
but we all know what you're saying hr
h.r crazy german
who designed all of the creatures uh and
alien technology from the original movie
alien
ridley scott's uh first science fiction
player yes and of course with um
sigourney weaver sigourney weaver tom
skerritt harry dean stanton one of
that's one of my top five
okay an amazing film i mean it's a
gothic horror film not a science fiction
movie but
uh i just my issue with it was that the
aliens still had
like a mouth or jaw teeth
yeah but he had a mouth and a mouth i
mean that's pretty creative yeah
no no i'm just thinking most life forms
on earth
do not have a mouth and teeth like trees
and worms
and butterflies and this sort of thing
so i if you're gonna have a complete
alien
you should be more creative than even
that
like the blob 1958 steve mcqueen movie
yes that's got no bones nothing it's
just a block it's terrifying
what was it it was a block it was a
block it was completely terrifying and
it would eat your blood
suck your blood and you know when the
blob first landed you know what color it
was
it was transparent it only turned red
after it ate its first victim
yes you didn't know that i did that oh
you didn't know that
i know that okay so and it can come
through the vents
into the thickness yeah so that's to me
that's creativity yeah
okay so i i i don't think that you can
say to yourself
i want to think of something that's
never been thought i think you have to
just keep on thinking
what do i what do i want that doesn't
exist
what do i want to make extent that that
i can't
obtain or i can't get right oh so your
urges are guiding your creativity
totally oh there you go absolutely and
that actually that's what this book is
to me it's a permission slip
to everyone to follow those weird urges
i call them secret thrill
so you shouldn't titled it follow your
weird urges
be a best seller overnight the publisher
rejected that song
is it too late to change the title
because that's a damn good time let's
just remove the cover
right right follow your weird characters
i know what i'm signing in your book
neil
so so we have to go into lightning round
now okay
okay we've got a few minutes left okay i
need from you sound bite answers
okay are you ready yep chuck go all
right here we go this is olivia waits
from instagram she wants to know how
long does it take to usually come up
with a truly
new idea ah that is impossible to
quantify
next there you go can a slicker system
let me ask what's the longest and
shortest time it took you to come up
with a new idea
oh yeah just gonna get the range
quantified to range between one minute
and 17 hours
okay good there you go i'll i'll accept
that one out of here
sorry we were looking for two days
wrong answer all right go here we go
uh connected canasta liquor
what oh that doesn't even i think
somebody made nevermind what is your
most unique
out of left field inspiration that has
ever happened to you or even surprised
you
that is weird where did you find
inspiration in a place that you never
thought you would
good oh wow i'm i'm going to need time
to think about that one i don't have a
a a sound by dancing to the end of the
show okay okay here we go uh
julie let me let me re word that
question uh
maybe it's the same question among all
your sources of inspiration what has
been the most fertile
uh reading actually always reading about
the first experiment of something that
was discovered
breeding fizzo's speed of light
experiment is so thrilling
okay good good wow what a great answer
an even better question
uh sorry it was in doppler fiji it's a
in late 19th century early he calculated
the speed of light with the clockwork
and mirrors okay here we go next there
we go
uh this is juliet from nbc says or from
says if you had unlimited resources
and time what would you build
oh i'd build a spaceship and i'd go to
the moon and then i'd go to mars
with unlimited resources and materials
yeah totally i would start some
interplanetary exploration beautiful
love
it all right this office i love that all
right last question no no no no no
that's it i
don't think we have to there we go final
reflection chuck give me
your final reflection um i am going to
now
pursue my weird urges i am
really happy legal go forward i'm happy
i have permission to do so okay
adam you got this book
presumably there's still stuff in you
that's not in this book otherwise buy
the book and we don't have to ever watch
you again
right joe oh yeah i held some stuff tell
me something's not in the book that we
should carry with us
oh wow
um that all human beings really want to
do is tell each other stories
and it's how it's that's both science
and art it's how we understand the
universe
even if the story you're telling is how
to build something indeed
oh i like it very nice so what i'd like
to think if i can add to an earlier
question
about creativity to have a
thought to see what everyone else has
seen
and think what no one else has thought
that's a commonly invoked definition of
genius
but maybe it's not genius that we're
honoring there maybe it's
hard work where you have a lot of
dangling thoughts within you because
you've read
a lot of books you've seen a lot of
movies you've spoken to a lot of people
you've done a lot of tinkering and they
they're sitting there waiting in your
head
and then you walk amid
all of these dangling parts and you say
give me
two bits of that one part of that one
part of this because they're available
to you to draw from
and out of that comes a brand new idea a
grant brand new object
a brand new concept so i think
the people who are cited as the great
inventors and geniuses of the world
are simply those who have more bits and
pieces in their lives
waiting to be assembled into something
new hmm
i totally agree very nicely
it's beautiful that you agree because i
pull that
from the cosmic perspective
adam thanks for being on star talk chuck
as always always
my man you've been listening to
possibly even watching this episode of
star talk
featuring adam savage formerly of
mythbusters and now he's just
making stuff and he's got a science
channel program that i can't wait to
catch give me the name of it again
savage builds savage build nice sounds
angry
june june 12th
summer 2019 on the science channel
i've been your host neil degrasse tyson
and as always i bid you
to keep looking up this episode is
brought to you by curiosity stream a
subscription streaming service made for
viewers with inquiring minds
including star talk fans just like you
get access starting at 299 a month let
me tell you about
curiosity streams how to build series
if you're a person that's a maker and
you want to step up your garage
game well this is the show for you it
gives you
unprecedented access to some of the
world's most advanced engineers who are
responsible for satellites
supercars and the wings of jumbo jets
their satellites episode is really cool
they talk about how to build a machine
that will live
for over a decade in space
and of course how it will deal with the
harshness of the environment of space
and the suspense about getting it into
orbit go to curiositystream.com
star talk for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series
and for our listeners enter the promo
code star talk when you're prompted
during the sign up process
and your membership is completely free
for the first 31 days
you